[Music]
we have the opportunity to work together
with a variety of different voices
colleagues from all over the world
who have different
um
strengths that they bring different
perspectives that they bring about life
and about how the world operates and
only when we bring those voices together
where we have a more complete picture
about how the living world works
so in order to uh
really solve the problems of the future
we're going to need to work together as
a global community problems are not
solved in isolation they're solved in
collaborative groups with other people
and they're solved to be realistic so
you have to consider not just your own
discipline or your own science but also
some economics and ethics and other
things that relate to the real world to
help you reach a real world but sensible
solution so it requires combining all
those different ways of thinking being
communicative and problem solving and
working with other people so that you
can reach solutions that actually
benefit the world because some solutions
are going to be great on paper but in
practice they aren't really practical so
that's why using new ways of thinking to
solve problems is really important as an
example for me in my phd project i um
even though my background has been in
biology the problem that i really that
really
captured my interest and that i wanted
to pursue
involves mechanics and and physics
and so it required learning a lot of
some deep um
theories and ideas and physics that i
wouldn't have thought of before and now
i kind of approach it sort of changed
the way that i approach biological
problems now i have this physics lens
that i didn't have before and that
expands the
possibilities of experiments i can think
of or hypotheses that i could have for
how something works